hey Aaron you got back from da plays you
got to check out Watson played a little
bit at the L star excited to check out
you know battle charge on the second but
you know tell me how she feels and you
know what you played with yeah we
actually we actually became champions
with Watson in one round which is kind
of awesome now granted people aren't
really used to her abilities yet but
she's supposed to be a anti charger so
she's basically a character who can put
up fences she can put up a lot of fences
I think that was one of the biggest
takeaways when I was playing with her is
that it's up to 12 and I think this is
gonna be a big deal of the beginning of
rounds in particular when people are
well-armed but even later on you can you
can go through a checkpoint you can set
up a couple of fences and you can even
come back later and link more fences to
those fences so there was once or twice
where we were like fighting over a hill
and fighting back and I was basically
like laying fences and covering us as we
retreated those fences do three things
so they will ping a character an enemy
character who runs through them they'll
do a little bit of damage and they will
slow that character so in particular
we're talking to developers about octane
and he said he wasn't sure if it would
cancel octane stim but it would actually
like definitely slow down octane so it
the thing about these fences is I'm not
sure if they'll ever completely stop
anybody kind of like Helen you know
Bangalore first appeared and you know
when the game launched and nobody ran
into her smoke and then all of a sudden
everybody ran to her smoke so we'll see
what happens in the meadow over time
these fences might end up being more
alert systems than then like something
people will be fully afraid to run
through yeah but they'll give your team
a lot of visit they'll give your team an
idea of like what's around you and
particularly if someone's trying to
flank you so unfortunately I don't think
you got your chance to capture any
gameplay even though you like you said
you won a match so you know obviously
some of the footage you're seeing here
is not you know representative of Watson
or the L star you know who do you think
she plays well with like in terms of
composition like who would you pair
Watson with as a team to like you know
really succeed with her so the developer
mentioned she pairs really well
kostik particularly in the last circle
she can set up all she can set up her
defenses fences literally and she can
also set up her interceptor pylon where
she can get only using one ultimate
accelerant so she can stockpile ultimate
accelerants and then at the end of a
round actually just eat one put down the
grenade interceptor eat one put down a
grenade interceptor and and then have a
caustic set up his traps and you
basically have an environment where
people can't throw grenades or any
throwables into it they get alerted or
they alert the other team if they enter
it and then they get gas and start
taking extra damage so she can be very
effective if you can cordon off an area
so one really interesting thing about
the interception pylons which is her
grenade interceptor is it only takes one
ultimate accelerant to get one down so
you can throw and down eat an ultimate
accelerant get one down they have a
surprisingly huge range for example I
threw and down and bangalore's like
metal rain ultimate came down of our
Rolling Thunder and it actually was like
zapping her her ordnance out of the sky
as it came down it almost like negated a
section of her Rolling Thunder which was
really fascinating that's crazy because
like you would think that could happen
on gibraltars all potentially or just
about a bunch of other things actually
this might be kind of like what happened
in in titanfall where anything that's
actually a physical projectile can can
can maybe be stopped by it not like guns
but any sort of throwable including some
of the Ultimates so that was really
really cool um one other thing I would
like to mention is it actually protects
the fence so you can destroy the fence
we I didn't I didn't do it myself but
they said you could throw a grenade in
front of the fence and blow up the
pylons so there are ways to destroy the
defense pylons
but this interceptor will stop that from
happening so it reinforces everything
that you do with the fence and what
might happen is you might get to the
last circle and there's just gonna be a
giant massive fences and then all these
grenades and receptors everywhere and
it's gonna be tough to break in now
people who counter her probably octane
and Pathfinder because they can probably
both go up and over her fences and sort
of negate
was kind of her ability yeah but you
also got to check out the L star it
looked pretty amazing at least in the
trailer like how did it feel to use it
was it as opie as a developer on the
stage said it was and how does it
compare kind of to some of the other
packaged weapons you know the crater and
the Mastiff the L star is a much more
straightforward weapon I feel like a lot
of the care packages drop items that are
specialty and you have to be kind of
good at them but the L star is basically
just a very strong like LMG class energy
weapon it does have a pretty quick
overheat mechanic so you have to you
know feather it or like back off a
little bit but in general I think it's
gonna be sort of the layman's thing that
you pull out of that package the care
packages it's very effective and it's
definitely something you notice when
somebody's shooting it and I got my
hands on it I dropped a couple players
while playing it as Watson so yeah it's
probably like the least specialty item
that comes out of those care packages
gotcha
they did say that when the event starts
they will drop them more often to get
people used to them at the beginning of
rounds and then as the next season
progresses they'll just move back
towards end of rounds we're more likely
to drop at the end of around cool yeah
looking forward to you know battle
charge obviously we're like a couple
weeks away
you know the hunt events going on right
now any final thoughts in terms of just
like what you played are you excited to
kind of like play now that there is a
new legend or yeah where your thoughts
as somebody who enjoys defensive
characters I know you really like
hard-charging characters though Watson
really gives you
she's much faster than you then you
would think like she can put down fences
very quickly that you don't really have
to in the in the developer event they
imply that you had to plan everything
out that's not really true with her you
can actually do a lot of things on the
fly with her so she's like a very fast
defensive character and I think she'll
go a long way towards having teams stop
just charging you every three seconds as
soon as they see you all right that was
great insight from Erin in terms of his
hands on experience with Watson and the
L star I'm looking forward to learning
the
character on July 2nd when bow charge
comes out
[Music]